only on CBS this morning we have a
first-hand look at the search for a US
aircraft carrier lost from us 77 years
the research vessel vessel petrol made
history in 2017 when it discovered the
wreck of the USS Indianapolis which was
sunk in the Pacific by a Japanese
submarine in World War two now that same
crew is focusing on the USS Hornet the
aircraft carrier launched 1942 s famous
Doolittle bombing raid on Tokyo the crew
invited Mark Phillips along for the
expedition in the South Pacific east of
the Solomon Islands good morning and
welcome to somewhere in the South
Pacific and to the search for the USS
Hornet one of the most fabled carriers
of the Second World War you might think
looking for an aircraft carrier
something so big would be a
straightforward thing but it's a big
ocean and around here it's about three
miles deep and the first question is
where to start looking the search begins
in iron bottom sound' the infamous
graveyard for ships and men around
Guadalcanal where some of the most
intense and costly naval battles of the
Second World War were fought and where
the research vessel petrol and her crew
begin the hunt for a wreck that's been
lost for 77 years carriers on both sides
were under almost constant air attack
the Hornet was engaged in the 1942
battle for control of the skies over
Guadalcanal US forces fought off counter
blows where US Marines were holding a
crucial airstrip the Japanese
desperately wanted back
it was a new kind of sea war with the
plane is functioning as the principal
attack weapon dive bomber on his way
down with his tracer bullets coming out
of his wings right at me
we spoke to Richard nowasky on a video
link he was 18 that day on the Hornet
he's 95 now the two torpedoes that came
in took that Hornet and shook it just
like a dog with a bone
and then we started listening over to
the right and no power we stopped dead
in the water the Hornet was finished a
hundred and forty of her crew were dead
the rest ordered to abandon ship
the Japanese then sank her the tactical
victory for the enemy the Hornet became
another wartime tragedy another lost
grave the petrol has come to try to find
it in the vast South Pacific Ocean 140
square miles of ocean is which this is
needle-in-a-haystack countries what
you're talking yeah absolutely
Rob Kraft and his team have done their
homework that's when they change course
to go east in a project funded by the
late Microsoft co-founder Paul Allen who
had a passion for maritime history
they've outfitted a state-of-the-art
deep-sea research vessel here this is
hour by hour information they've gone
over records from other ships involved
in the battle and plotted where those
ships thought they were but in battle
records are often unreliable there's an
actual ship's log they even looked at
records in the Japanese naval archives
from the ships that sank the Hornet so
the u.s. narrative and the Japanese
Imperial Navy wartime Navy's logs both
point to the same rough place yeah in
close proximity so that you know that's
a good clue take her away Rudy a good
enough clue to go have a look the petrol
drops a torpedo shaped underwater drone
over the side
everyone it's programmed to dive down in
this case more than three miles down and
to scan the bottom with sonar waves
looking for something that shouldn't
naturally be there we've got about an
hour hour and a half trip down to the
bottom and she'll start it first survey
it's a tense time only when the thing is
retrieved I start breaking it nice and
slow and it's data examined does the
crew know if it's found anything the
data shows mile after mile of empty
seabed until that looks like debris it
does look like a debris doesn't it has
it found something you have something
here you can see the the difference here
if I don't out left what does that look
like
that looks suspiciously like a ship but
is it enough to warrant another dive I'm
thinking about him he didn't think the
long get two guys spun up yeah all right
only the petrels camera laden remotely
operated sub can find out in his
spaceship these ship three two one
splash and she's on her way down they
don't just have dive machines aboard
this vessel they have time machines
things that go down through the water
and back into the past the search for
the Hornet three miles down and from 77
years ago continues tomorrow and in
marks report tomorrow and CBS this
morning we'll find out if the crew
actually discovered the aircraft carrier
or were met with just another
frustrating example of false hopes more
on that tomorrow and we'll be right back